hi my name is tig notaro and i feel gay
about being conan o'brien's friend
that's a first and i'll
i'm clocking that laughter as hate crime
did you see that i did not laugh
i solemnly not i'm not looking over
there and it was matt gourley who left
and laughed at the idea that someone
could even be gay which i thought was
terrible yeah oh wait yeah you're gay
yeah i am dabbling i've been dabbling
for decades okay not sold on it when are
you going pro
even in the minor leagues of gay why are
you laughing at that
i was laughing at the whole concept i
was laughing at the whole concept of
minor league teams i don't think those
people are paid enough was gay involved
in that at all because i find that to be
a very solemn issue solemn is the word i
would use
um about being my friend
no i don't
look
sexuality i feel gay about being conan
o'brien uh and um and i think that's a
good thing i really do i love me um and
i'm attracted to me when i catch my when
i catch a look at myself in the mirror
or any kind of shiny surface i'm
entranced
i really am i think i'm a good-looking
tall drink of water yeah um
i think i'm a fun raccoon tour you don't
hear that often i don't
um i don't hear it nearly enough well
i'm going to say it a few more times
i am a recontour
uh and i think an absolute delight right
sona um no i would disagree
i would disagree tensioning here is
incredible yeah um tig i'm gonna preface
everything i say now uh by telling you
how much i adore you which you know is
true yep um wow you're just checking
things off the list aren't you
compliment check
um
and uh you're
a hilariously funny person yep and i
very much enjoyed every time i've had a
chance to perform with you or talk to
you
yep
and
yet i feel like there's a lot of [ __ ]
you and i need to straighten out between
us you know i think there's some bad
vibes
and uh we need to get this stuff out on
the table and we need to talk about it
that's why i'm here okay
you walk in here with some
um i don't know sparkling water yeah but
pops in it yes it's sparkling water with
hops in it and this is not an ad or
anything but it's lagunitas
hoppy refresher and it's got a very sort
of niche appeal it feels um very good it
feels very hipster i would not say gay i
would not say gay i would not okay but
bicurious has a bicurious vibe to it it
does okay i'll say it it has a bicurious
vibe to it bicarbonate yeah thank you
very much both bicarbonate and bicurious
and um so i thought we'd start there
we'd start on this drink that you
introduced yes which felt like an
aggressive move you came in here with
this aggressively
cool drink yeah uh hipstery drink and
you're sipping it and you're really
enjoying it is it hipstery why it's
hopster don't worry about that he
doesn't understand
anything he doesn't recognize is hip
yeah okay yeah exactly if i'm presented
with any kind of math problem i say oh
this hipster jargon yeah it's just
because i'm not good at math i don't
understand well you should hang out at
my house because my son finn
is obsessed with math that's a good
thing and it comes from his obsession
with sports and he wakes up every
morning
gets on stephanie's phone stephanie of
course is my husband gets on stephanie's
phone check stats
five in the morning right when he rolls
out of bed i think that's cool that's
great when they have an interest yeah
like that
i wasn't saying it was uncool i'm just
trying to move the conversation along
you felt it needed moving i thought we
were rolling along nicely
oh okay you felt we had a flat and we're
stuck in a ditch
and you got out rolled up your sleeves
and got the car going again so i guess
you're the hero of this situation
um
god i'm so enraged and i don't know why
talking to someone i adore do you like
some hops no i will not have your hoppy
hipstery drink
um
my son
has i mean i just love that when you
have kids i have two kids
that's one yeah two two yeah there's two
and there's um
my son is just so talented and good at
math and coding i don't know where that
comes from it doesn't come from me i
don't think it comes from my wife
but
but it was present when he was like one
and a half years old he once just wanted
to push buttons you remember i'd bring
him by the office
he's always liked it yeah and he just
always wanted to get near a keyboard and
start just pushing buttons and then
accidentally he'd you know program a
missile to fire into russia and it
caused a lot of problems but uh actually
we visited the white house once yeah and
they took us a tour of the situation
room and he pushed a button in the
situation room and a guy came in and
went is everything okay oh my god we
were like what do you mean
he was like five
wow
and he had pushed a button in the
situation room which is in the basement
of uh the white house and a guy came in
and said the you know we're in trouble
button was pushed
and my son was there and he's like it's
a button you push buttons so why are
they letting you in the situation also
why are they calling it the we're in
trouble button
let's take these one at a time okay okay
they call it the we're in trouble button
because everyone immediately knows what
it means yes and it's there's a lot of
here's the problem it's a lot of writing
it's a very long sentence on a very
small button so you can't really make it
out second of all why was i in the
situation room yeah consultation come on
i am brought in occasionally i was
during the obama administration still in
the bite administration i am brought in
to consult on foreign management role
playing the catastrophe oh okay okay
everyone's really laughing up the storm
but you could see that uh they they want
to get conan's hot take and so they
they they bring me in and i've done that
many times no that never happened i did
it for truman i did it for eisenhower
did it for kennedy uh i've done you know
whatever i do my part for my country
okay but anyway he was always obsessed
with me absolutely
well how come you're not saluting your
arm your arms are folded every podcast
so you say we salute you yet you refuse
to salute that's right you let the
listeners at home imagine all the
saluting that's going on
well i would like to say that your
your arms are folded very defiantly
the opposite of us
it is as far from a salute as i can
possibly imagine well you know my
delivery is slow so this is the
beginning of a salute it takes a little
while for my arms to uncross and then
the saluting
it goes haywire this is like watching a
flower bloom
you can speed up the footage and we'd
see if we sped it up incredibly we'd see
an actual salute that's right but uh if
i actually want to see it play out it's
going to be like 15 hours and you have
to be in bright sunlight
that's funny because a flower has to be
in bright sunlight to bloom that's why
that's very funny wow oh wow oh
oh wow and can we
add laughs later is there a way that we
could add just people going crazy such
an easy laugher too sometimes yeah i
laughed at everything tigger said so far
i can extend the silence cricket
just crickets yeah do you um you know
what i always think when i hear crickets
that the crickets are at the show and
they enjoy it they're laughing that's a
way of crooked the crickets are showing
their appreciation isn't that the way
they mate so
you're making them want to mate yeah
that's my comedy has always led very
quickly to people doing it
um do your kids think you're funny do
they do you clown for them or
do do you give them the sort of dry
classic
tignotero uh delivery
well if it
matters to anyone it's notaro
but
oh god
there's some laughs
she's been on your show so many times i
just think it doesn't matter i know
that's why it really doesn't matter it
doesn't matter look if you come home how
many times have did regis philbin call
me conan for all of his entire life he
called me conan you did
regis philbin what do you mean ridge ice
file bin
okay here we go but i had never
complained and this is my way of showing
dominance complaining i said
if it matters
it's take notaro yeah i know um
and
yeah just tig that's right three g's
there was a while there i was calling
you jog remember i do i really i swear
to god i thought that you were from the
netherlands and i was saying it's chaog
no taro and you said please and then i
worked my way to take now we're at tig
notaro and we're right where we need to
be right
in progress that is right
um my
children
at times think i'm funny
i think
um you know we have laughs as a family
but um they're i'm not from social
services
i feel like i'm here with a clipboard
and are there occasional laughs there
are occasional laughs we do smile
we feel glad
there are things that make us feel glad
um
yeah
you know when they
they know that i
fly away and tell jokes um
but i they're so
there are not even six yet and so their
sense of humor
is um
you know it's a little silly and so
we get real silly at the house um yeah
they like my i have a an animated
stand-up special on hbo and they've
watched that over and over again i think
they really enjoy the animation and i
talk a lot about stephanie in it and so
they they love that too
they must be i mean that's a kid's dream
is to see their uh one of their parents
as a cartoon
yeah i would think it seems like that's
what they are most interested in when
they see
if my my other specials pop up or
something on a
platform
they call me tig they'll say oh there's
tig no taro
and
and what they call me is mare which is
french for mother but when they see me
in anything professional they say
there's tignotaro and then with star
trek
they want to fast forward through
anything and just see the spaceship fly
by
they they fast forward past your scenes
just to see the spaceship yes i think a
lot of people probably do that too
it's hard to compete with the spaceship
yeah yeah they look so cool right you
know when they're sort of arcing around
in orbit yeah you get to look at the
planet and the ship and kind of look at
the little twinkling lights
i do it too i'm just being honest with
you you fast forward through my parts to
the spaceship i've never seen you on it
i just see the ship over and over and i
actually i mean so isn't this true i had
you once go through all of those
episodes of star trek and remove all the
scenes that was just spaceship we had to
we had we halted production for a few
days just so we could get our crew to
edit out all of your scenes just so we
could get the spaceship six hundred
thousand dollars yeah it cost it's very
expensive yeah but i was like is that a
lot of money
nicely done
very nicely done
i'm told i'm told that's a lot of money
you know people say we live in a bubble
and i say no we don't because i happen
to know six hundred thousand dollars
that's like that's uh
what is that like that's like four meals
or something i mean it's ridiculous when
people have to go through
it's insane